bundeskanzler olaf scholz
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meinem
verehrten kolleginnen kollegen
fährt der kollege merz ich habe ihnen
eben sehr genau zugehört
ich will ihnen ich will ihn einst
antworten
unterschätzen sie unser land nicht
unterschätzen sie nicht die bürgerinnen
und bürger dieses landes
in schweren zeiten wächst unser land
über sich selbst hinaus wir haben eine
gute tradition uns unter zu haken wenn
es schwierig wird bund länder und
kommunen politik zivilgesellschaft
arbeitgeber und betriebsräte unternehmen
und gewerkschaften der spaltung
herbeiredet der gefährde den
zusammenhalt in diesem land und das ist
jetzt das falsche
[Applaus]
ja das mag so sein dass olaf scholz das
auch so sieht dass man sich da zusammen
unter die arme fast und gemeinsam
schreitet wie es ja auch immer bei den
sozialisten der fall gewesen ist das
große problem wird sein dass viele viele
firmen und viele privathaushalte
deswegen gibt es ja auch die sogenannten
entlastungsprogramm das völlig anders
sehen als olaf scholz die sind am ende
die müssen möglicherweise sogar
insolvenz anmelden und da bin ich
gespannt ob sich diese menschen dann
wirklich noch aufgehoben fühlen und
unterlagen und diese krise gemeinsam zu
beenden
entscheidungen zu treffen die
weitreichend sind und die weitreichend
auch jetzt schon umgesetzt worden sind
etwas auf dass niemand anders sich
vorbereitet hat
wir haben zb entschieden um mit dieser
bedrohung klarzukommen dass wir an den
norddeutschen küsten flüssiggasterminals
bauen dass wir die pipelines bauen die
dazu notwendig sind damit ihr unabhängig
von russland gas nach deutschland
importieren können wir haben die
kapazitäten aus den niederlanden aus
belgien jetzt aus frankreich erweitert
weil wir ein problem mit macht und uns
vorbereitet haben über das sie damals
noch nicht einmal gesprochen haben
und in einem tempo zudem keine cdu
geführte regierung in diesem land je
fähig gewesen ist werden wir es schaffen
im januar werden die ersten dieser
terminals ihren betrieb aufnehmen das
ist eine gemeinschaftsleistung in
deutschland
ja da macht es olaf scholz auch wieder
ein wenig einfach denn eins ist klar die
spd hat er mit angela merkel mitregiert
und zwar die letzten acht jahre also so
einfach kann sich olaf scholz nicht
machen da nur auf die cdu zu zeigen vor
allem weil er in der letzten regierung
ja finanzminister und vizekanzler war
dass sich das ändert mit gesetzen und
regeln die wir auf den weg gebracht
haben
sie hatten noch nicht mehr in der
opposition ist er fertig gebracht das
eigene versäumnisse als problem der
neuen regierung unterzuschieben wir
hatten es schon gelöst bevor sie
überhaupt mitbekommen haben dass da ein
2 das ist die wahrheit
und während wir mit den speicher für gas
in deutschland so unverantwortlich
vorgegangen wie das die zu vorher
verantwortlichen der verantwortliche
minister und die regierung gehabt haben
dann würde ich ihnen ausdrücklich sagen
hätten wir jetzt nicht 85%
speicherkapazität sondern quasi nichts
so wie im letzten jahr das ist der
unterschied zwischen der union und den
verteidigern das land sie hier
sie haben noch nicht mal gefordert dass
wir dafür sorgen sollen dass die
speicher voll sind und da haben wir die
gesetze schon gemacht sie könnten auch
mal sagen dass sie das eine
beeindruckende leistung finden hernals
[Applaus]
ja die generaldebatte verdient bis zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt wirklichen namen
heißt es dass schlagabtausch dieses märz
es mehr herbst durch entschuldung herbst
ist olaf scholz reagiert sehr sehr
emotional friedrich merz kennt man ihn
fast gar nicht in das macht spannend
zuzuhören zuzuschauen deswegen schnell
wieder zurück nicht abgeschaltet werden
alles das haben wir auf den weg gebracht
das war eine notwendige leistung mit
großer geschwindigkeit und großem tempo
die wir hier auf den weg gebracht haben
und sogar solche fragen wie diese hier
nebenbei angesprochenen sind längst
dabei gelöst zu werden wie zb das
natürlich die kohlekraftwerke loslegen
können auch wenn sie nicht genügend
gelagert haben und auch die tatsache ist
die biomasse anlagen dass die
solaranlagen alle aus alles an kraft
zeigen können was sie brauchen das haben
wir gesetzlich alles vorbereitet sie
brauchen nur noch zugucken wie das
geschieht es ist schon erledigt bevor
sie es ausgesprochen haben
und wir haben ein gesetz gemacht fuel
switch die gesetzlichen regelungen dafür
geschaffen dass überall in deutschland
betrieben unternehmen entscheidung
treffen können dass sie nicht auf gas
zurückgreifen müssen sondern andere
anlagen betreiben können damit wir
gemeinsam gas sparen oder durch diesen
winter kommen auch das haben diese schon
gemacht sie haben es noch nicht mal
gefordert
ja und ich weiß es ist schon sehr
enttäuschend weil sie sich so sehr auf
das thema der kernenergie konzentriert
haben aber das was wir jetzt vorbereiten
ist dass die möglichkeit besteht dass
wir die kernkraft anlagen die
atomanlagen im süden deutschlands
betreiben können damit es niemals an
strom lange in deutschland gibt auch
wenn das in diesem winter im januar
februar und märz notwendig ist das ist
vorbereitet und das ist die grundlage
dafür dass das ganze was sie sich schon
vor zwei wochen als rhetorisches konzept
erlegt import überlegt haben hier heute
gescheitert ist
sie reden einfach am thema und an den
problemen dieses landes vorbei und das
ist wirklich ein ganz ganz großes
problem und wenn andere die probleme
lösen die sie noch nicht mal erkannt
haben dann reden sie auch noch drum rum
[Applaus]
ja wir sehen einen sehr emotionalen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz unerwartet
emotional und muss das fast schon als
aufwertung auf von friedrich merz
verstehen denn die ersten fünf minuten
hat olaf scholz jetzt in seiner rede
fast ausschließlich zugebracht auf
friedrich merz zu antworten auf die
cdu/csu-fraktion chip und sich zu
verteidigen seine politik zu verteidigen
zu rechtfertigen das bedeutet natürlich
dass das was friedrich merz gesagt hat
olaf scholz durchaus zugesetzt hat hören
war ein am beginn des jahres sagen
können und weil wir so früh angefangen
haben als noch gar nicht ein so großes
problem problembewusstsein in
deutschland da war darum sind wir jetzt
in der lage dass wir tapfer und mutig in
diesem winter hinein gehen können dass
unser land das überstehen werde das ist
die sache die wir gemacht haben
insofern sind sie also schief gewickelt
wenn ich das mal so sagen dass sie haben
einfach an dem thema vorbei geredet dass
unser land wirklich umtreibt und wir
sind jetzt dabei die nächsten dinge zu
tun die notwendig sind damit die
bürgerinnen bürgern unsere wirtschaft
durch diese zeit
das gibt eine sehr mutige aussage von
olaf scholz friedrich merz vorzuwerfen
die ja die probleme der die probleme
geschildert hat der vorgetragen hat was
die menschen und auch die firmen und
treibt den jetzt vorzuwerfen er wäre mit
seiner rede schief gewickelt da muss
olaf scholz jetzt dramatisch aufpassen
dass er möglicherweise nicht schief
gewickelt ist und die dinge aus seiner
regierungsperspektive sieht aber nicht
mehr aus der sicht von firmenchefs
beispielsweise von angestellten von
rentnern und studenten wir haben zwei
erste paket von knapp 30 milliarden euro
bereits beschlossen jetzt kommt 1 noch
einmal dazu dass knapp 65 milliarden
euro umfasst alles zusammen eine
ziemlich große summe und es dient dazu
dass die bürgerinnen und bürger durch
diese zeit kommen dass die unternehmen
kommen durch die zeit kommen und dass
die arbeitsplätze gesichert werden you
never walk alone das ist das motto
dieser regierung
ich bin sicher unser land über sich
heraus wachsen wir werden zusammenhalten
wir werden die herausforderung bestehen
vor dem wir uns jetzt befinden und wir
werden die probleme lösen die wir
miteinander haben weil wir niemanden
alleine lassen mit seinen
herausforderungen und dazu dienen auch
all die entscheidungen die jetzt
getroffen haben zum beispiel die
entscheidung zu sagen dass jetzt wo in
diesem monat die energiepreis prämie
gezahlt wird das alles als möglichkeit
bei den arbeitnehmenden arbeitnehmern
ankommt haben wir auch entschieden dass
es auch für rentnerinnen und rentner und
studenten gelten soll das ist eine
entlastung in einer schwierigen zeit wo
alles teurer wird richtig dass wir das
tun
wir machen eine bürgergeld reformen die
dafür sorgt dass diejenigen die sehr
wenig geld haben auch durch diese zeit
kommen können dass sie unterstützt
werden aber vor allem sorgen wir dafür
dass teil diejenigen die diesem land
arbeiten oder als renten um rentner
einmal gearbeitet haben all die
unterstützung bekommen die sie brauchen
damit sie das finanzieren können was an
teuren lebenshaltungskosten bei ihnen
ankommt und das ist geschehen mit den
dingen die ich schon genannt habe aber
zb auch mit der größten wohngeldreform
seit der einführung des wohngelds in
diesem land zwei millionen berechtigte
stadt 700.000 das wird unglaublich viele
familien in diesem land besser stellen
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern mit
geringen einkommen und rentnern rente
eine richtige eine notwendige
entscheidung
zum beispiel indem wir dafür sorgen dass
familien unterstützt werden das
kindergeld wird erhöht die schritte die
für das nächste und das übernächste jahr
anfallen machen ziehen wir zusammen
machen es in ein schritt mit 18 euro wir
sorgen dafür dass der kinderzuschlag
verbessert wird da geht es für manche
familien um ein paar hundert euro im
jahr die sie mehr zur verfügung haben
eine richtige eine notwendige
entscheidung in dieser zeit
wir sorgen dafür dass diejenigen die
wenig verdienen und den wir mit
steuerentlastungen wenig helfen können
eine entlastung bekommen indem wir die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge für die sie
zahlen müssen absenken und dafür sorgen
dass bis zu einem einkommen von 2000
euro die progressionszone bei den
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen fortgesetzt
wird das sind über 1,3 milliarden euro
netto entlastung für diejenigen die am
wenigsten in diesem land verdienen und
von steuersenkung sonst nichts hätten
nicht zu vergessen dass gerade jetzt
wenn das stattfindet zum ersten oktober
der mindestlohn auf 12 euro angehoben
wird in einer solchen zeit eine dringend
notwendige entscheidung für die wir uns
lange eingesetzt haben meine damen und
herren
und wir entlasten die bürgerinnen und
bürger in dem wir steuersenkung
beschließen im großen umfang in dem wir
auf die inflation reagieren und
dementsprechend das flächendeckend
organisieren mit der anhebung des
freibetrages mit den steuer senken damit
verbunden sind übrigens verknüpft mit
lauter maßnahmen die wir jetzt auf den
weg bringen oder schon auf den weg
gebracht haben wie zb dass die
rentenbeiträge abgezogen werden können
vom steuereinkommen voller höhe das sind
die beiden nächsten jahre zusammen fünf
milliarden euro entlastung für
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmer eine
richtige entscheidung und eine
notwendige entscheidung
[Applaus]
der bundeskanzler zählt jetzt noch
einmal auf das was an entlastung geplant
ist wobei man bei dem wort entlastung
auch immer ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
muss denn klar ist gerade das thema
steuern dass olaf scholz gerade
angesprochen hat es nicht so einfach zu
sehen viele werden ja aufgrund der
inflation und damit einhergehender
lohnerhöhungen sogar mehr belastet
deswegen ist das was da passiert in
genaugenommen sinne keine entlastung zum
ersten ersten 23 nur eine wegnahme der
belastung ein bisschen kompliziert aber
das sollte der fairness halber einmal
gesagt hat also keine echte entlastung
sondern nur eine zurückstellung des
steuertarifs auf alte niveaus
deren entscheidungen und die aktivitäten
der unternehmen unterstützen indem wir
sagen wenn jetzt wegen dieser preis
streuung der höheren energiekosten die
sozialpartner die gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeber vereinbaren das ist höhere
sonderzahlungen gibt dann werden wir bis
zu 3000 euro steuer- und abgabenfrei
ermöglichen das ist eine konkrete
botschaft des zusammenhalts in
deutschland und eine botschaft der tat
partnerschaft
sinn wenn also wir haben sehr viel
gemacht um die drängenden probleme
vieler bürgerinnen und bürger in den
griff zu bekommen und wir werden das
auch weiter tun weil das notwendig ist
die maßnahmen die wir gemacht haben
haben wir auch große erfahrung mit sich
gebracht viele haben hier sehr skeptisch
diskutiert ich erinnere mich an einige
äußerungen aus der union wenn ich das
richtig dass wir das neun euro ticket
einführen und ich sage ausdrücklich das
war eine große sache die skeptiker
hatten nicht recht und deshalb wird es
eine fortsetzung geben für eine lösung
die das wirklich macht bundesweit
abonnierbare digital buchbare tickets zu
haben die zu einem vertretbaren tarif
überall in deutschland die nutzung des
nahverkehrs möglich machen eine gute
entscheidung aus der krise gewachsen
aber für viel viel längere zeit
sinnvollen
was dann natürlich dazu kommt ist dass
wir die herausforderung bewältigen
müssen die mit den steigenden
energiekosten verbunden sind kollegen
fährt der kollege merz ich habe ihnen
eben sehr genau zugehört
ich will ihnen ich will ihn einst
antworten
unterschätzen sie unser land nicht
unterschätzen sie nicht die bürgern und
bürger dieses landes
in schweren zeiten wächst unser land
über sich selbst hinaus wir haben eine
gute tradition und unter zu halten wenn
es schwierig wird bund länder und
kommunen politik zivilgesellschaft
arbeitgeber und betriebsräte unternehmen
und gewerkschaften der spaltung
herbeiredet der gefährdet den
zusammenhalt in diesem land und das ist
jetzt das falsche
[Applaus]
ja das mag so sein dass olaf scholz das
auch so sieht dass man sich da zusammen
unter die arme fast und gemeinsam
schreitet wie es ja auch immer bei den
sozialisten der fall gewesen ist das
große problem wird sein dass viele viele
zonen und viele privathaushalte deswegen
gibt es ja auch die sogenannten
entlastungsprogramm das völlig anders
sehen als olaf scholz die sind am ende
die müssen möglicherweise sogar
insolvenz anmelden und da bin ich
gespannt ob sich diese menschen dann
wirklich noch aufgehoben fühlen und
unterlagen und diese krise gemeinsam zu
beenden
entscheidungen zu treffen die
weitreichend sind und die weitreichend
auch jetzt schon umgesetzt worden sind
etwas auch dass niemand anders sich
vorbereitet hat
wir haben zum beispiel entschieden um
mit dieser bedrohung klarzukommen dass
wir an den norddeutschen küsten
flüssiggasterminals bauen dass wir die
pipelines bauen die dazu notwendig sind
damit ihr unabhängig von russland gas
nach deutschland importieren können wir
haben die kapazitäten aus den
niederlanden aus belgien jetzt aus
frankreich erweitert weil wir ein
problem mit macht und uns vorbereitet
haben über das sie damals noch nicht
einmal gesprochen haben
und in einem tempo zudem keine cdu
geführte regierung in diesem land je
fertig gewesen ist werden wir es
schaffen im januar werden die ersten
dieser terminals ihren betrieb aufnehmen
das ist eine gemeinschaftsleistung in
deutschland
ja da macht es olaf scholz auch wieder
ein wenig einfach denn eins ist klar die
spd hat er mit angela merkel mitregiert
und zwar die letzten acht jahre also so
einfach kann sich olaf scholz nicht
machen da nur auf die cdu zu zeigen vor
allem weil er in der letzten regierung
ja finanzminister und vizekanzler war
dass sich das ändert mit gesetzen und
regeln die wir auf den weg gebracht
haben
sie hatten noch nicht mehr in der
opposition ist der fertiggebracht das
eigene versäumnisse als problem der
neuen regierung unterzuschieben wir
hatten es schon gelöst bevor sie
überhaupt mitbekommen haben das war
einst war das ist die wahrheit oder
gerechnet
und während wir mit den speicher für gas
in deutschland so und fahren konnte ich
vorgegangen wie das die zu vorher
verantwortlichen der vorher
verantwortliche minister und die
regierung gehabt haben dann würde ich
ihnen ausdrücklich sagen hätten wir
jetzt nichts 85% speicherkapazität
sondern quasi nichts so wie im letzten
jahr das ist der unterschied zwischen
der union und den verteilt jetzt das
land regieren
sie haben noch nicht mal gefordert dass
wir dafür sorgen sollen dass die
speicher voll sind und da haben wir die
gesetze schon gemacht sie könnten auch
mal sagen dass sie das eine
beeindruckende leistung finden herr merz
[Applaus]
ja die generaldebatte verdient bis zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt wirklichen namen
heißt es dass schlagabtausch dieses märz
es mehr herbst durch entschuldung herbst
ist olaf scholz reagiert sehr sehr
emotionaler friedrich merz so kennt man
ihn fast gar nicht es macht spannend
zuzuhören zuzuschauen deswegen schnell
wieder zurück nicht abgeschaltet werden
alles das haben wir auf den weg gebracht
das war eine notwendige leistung mit
großer geschwindigkeit und großem tempo
die wir hier auf den weg gebracht haben
und sogar solche fragen wie diese hier
nebenbei angesprochen sind längst dabei
gelöst zu werden wie zb das natürlich
die kohlekraftwerke loslegen können auch
wenn sie nicht genügend gelagert haben
und auch die tatsache ist die biomasse
anlagen dass die solaranlagen alle aus
alles an kraft zeigen können was sie
brauchen das haben wir gesetzlich alles
vorbereitet sie brauchen nur noch
zugucken wie das geschieht es ist schon
erledigt bevor sie es ausgesprochen
haben
und wir haben ein gesetz gemacht fuel
switch die gesetzlichen regelungen dafür
geschaffen dass überall in deutschland
betriebe und unternehmen entscheidungen
treffen können dass sie nicht auf gast
zurückgreifen müssen sondern andere
anlagen betreiben können damit wir
gemeinsam gas sparen und durch diesen
winter kommt auch das haben diese schon
gemacht sie haben es noch nicht mal
gefordert
ja und ich weiß es ist für sie sehr
enttäuschend weil sie sich so sehr auf
das thema der kernenergie konzentriert
haben aber das was wir jetzt vorbereiten
ist dass die möglichkeit besteht dass
wir die kernkraft anlagen die
atomanlagen im süden deutschlands
betreiben können damit es niemals ein
strom lange in deutschland gibt auch
wenn das in diesem winter im januar
februar und märz notwendig ist das ist
vorbereitet und das ist die grundlage
dafür dass das ganze was sie sich schon
vor zwei wochen als rhetorisches konzept
erlegt import überlegt haben hier heute
gescheitert ist
sie reden einfach am thema und an den
problemen dieses landes vorbei und das
ist wirklich ein ganz ganz großes
problem und wenn andere die probleme
lösen die sie noch nicht mal erkannt
haben dann reden sie auch noch drumherum
[Applaus]
ja wir sehen einen sehr emotionalen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz unerwartet
emotional und muss das fast schon als
aufwertung auf von friedrich merz
verstehen denn die ersten fünf minuten
hat olaf scholz jetzt in seiner rede
fast ausschließlich zugebracht auf
friedrich merz zu antworten auf die
cdu/csu-fraktion sap und sich zu
verteidigen seine politik zu verteidigen
zu rechtfertigen das bedeutet natürlich
dass das was friedrich merz gesagt hat
olaf scholz durchaus zugesetzt hat hören
war ein beginn des jahres sagen können
und weil wir so früh angefangen haben
als noch gar nicht ein so großes problem
problembewusstsein in deutschland da war
darum sind wir jetzt in der lage dass
wir tapfer und mutig in diesem winter
hinein gehen können dass unser land das
überstehen werde das ist die sache die
wir gemacht haben
insofern sind sie also schief gewickelt
wenn ich das mal so sagen darf sie haben
einfach an dem thema vorbei geredet dass
unser land wirklich umtreibt und wir
sind jetzt dabei die nächsten dinge zu
tun die notwendig sind damit die
bürgerinnen bürger und unsere wirtschaft
durch diese
das gibt eine sehr mutige aussage von
olaf scholz friedrich merz vorzuwerfen
die ja die probleme der die probleme
geschildert hat der vorgetragen hat was
die menschen und auch die firmen und
treibt den jetzt vorzuwerfen er wäre mit
seiner rede schief gewickelt da muss
olaf scholz jetzt dramatisch aufpassen
dass er möglicherweise nicht schief
gewickelt ist und die dinge aus seiner
regierungsperspektive sieht aber nicht
mehr aus der sicht von firmenchefs
beispielsweise von angestellten von
rentnern und studenten wir haben zwei
erste paket von knapp 30 milliarden euro
bereits beschlossen jetzt kommt 1 noch
einmal dazu dass knapp 65 milliarden
euro umfasst alles zusammen eine
ziemlich große summe und es dient dazu
dass die bürgerinnen und bürger durch
diese zeit kommen dass die unternehmen
kommen durch die zeit kommen und dass
die arbeitsplätze gesichert werden you
never walk alone das ist das motto
dieser regierung
ich bin sicher unser land über sich
heraus wachsen wir werden zusammenhalten
wir werden die herausforderung bestehen
vor dem wir uns jetzt befinden und wir
werden die probleme lösen die wir
miteinander haben weil wir niemanden
alleine lassen mit seinen
herausforderungen und dazu dienen auch
all die entscheidungen die jetzt
getroffen haben zum beispiel die
entscheidung zu sagen dass jetzt wo in
diesem monat die energiepreis prämie
gezahlt wird das anders als möglichkeit
bei den arbeitnehmenden arbeitnehmern
ankommt haben wir auch entschieden dass
es auch für rentnerinnen und rentner und
studenten gelten soll das ist eine
entlastung in einer schwierigen zeit wo
alles teurer wird richtig dass wir das
tun
wir machen eine bürgergeld reformen die
dafür sorgt dass diejenigen die sehr
wenig geld haben auch durch diese zeit
kommen können dass sie unterstützt
werden aber vor allem sorgen wir dafür
dass teil diejenigen die diesem land
arbeiten oder als renten um rentner
einmal gearbeitet haben all die
unterstützung bekommen die sie brauchen
damit sie das finanzieren können was an
teuren lebenshaltungskosten bei ihnen
ankommt und das ist geschehen mit den
dingen die ich schon genannt habe aber
zb auch mit der größten wohngeldreform
seit der einführung des wohngelds in
diesem land zwei millionen berechtigte
stadt 700.000 das wird unglaublich viele
familien in diesem land besser stellen
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmern mit
geringen einkommen und rentnern rente
eine richtige eine notwendige
entscheidung
zum beispiel indem wir dafür sorgen dass
familien unterstützt werden das
kindergeld wird erhöht die schritte die
für das nächste und das übernächste jahr
anfallen machen ziehen wir zusammen
machen es in ein schritt mit 18 euro wir
sorgen dafür dass der kinderzuschlag
verbessert wird da geht es für manche
familien um ein paar hundert euro im
jahr die sie mehr zur verfügung haben
eine richtige eine notwendige
entscheidung in dieser zeit
wir sorgen dafür dass diejenigen die
wenig verdienen und den wir mit
steuerentlastungen wenig helfen können
eine entlastung bekommen indem wir die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge für die sie
zahlen müssen absenken und dafür sorgen
dass bis zu einem einkommen von 2000
euro die progressionszone bei den
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen fortgesetzt
wird das sind über 1,3 milliarden euro
netto entlastung für diejenigen die am
wenigsten in diesem land verdienen und
von steuersenkung sonst nichts hätten
nicht zu vergessen dass gerade jetzt
wenn das stattfindet zum ersten oktober
der mindestlohn noch zwölf euro
angehoben wird in einer solchen zeit
eine dringend notwendige entscheidung
für die wir uns lange eingesetzt haben
meine damen und herren
und wir entlasten die bürgerinnen und
bürger in dem wir steuersenkung
beschließen im großen umfang in dem wir
auf die inflation reagieren und
dementsprechend das flächendeckend
organisieren mit der anhebung des
freibetrages mit den steuer senken damit
verbunden sind übrigens verknüpft mit
lauter maßnahmen die wir jetzt auf den
weg bringen oder schon auf den weg
gebracht haben wie zb dass die
rentenbeiträge abgezogen werden können
vom steuereinkommen voller höhe das sind
die beiden nächsten jahre zusammen fünf
milliarden euro entlastung für
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmer eine
richtige entscheidung und eine
notwendige entscheidung
[Applaus]
der bundeskanzler zählt jetzt noch
einmal auf das was an entlastung geplant
ist wobei man bei den board entlastung
auch immer ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
muss denn klar ist gerade das thema
steuern dass olaf scholz gerade
angesprochen hat ist nicht so einfach zu
sehen viele werden ja aufgrund der
inflation und damit einhergehender
lohnerhöhungen sogar mehr belastet
deswegen ist das was da passiert in
genau genommen im sinne keine entlastung
zum ersten ersten 23 nur eine wegnahme
der belastung ein bisschen kompliziert
aber das sollte der fairness halber
einmal gesagt hat also keine echte
entlastung sondern nur eine
zurückstellung des steuertarifs alte
niveaus und wir werden deren
entscheidungen und die aktivitäten der
unternehmen unterstützen indem wir sagen
wenn jetzt wegen dieser preis steuerung
der höheren energiekosten die
sozialpartner die gewerkschaften und die
arbeitgeber vereinbaren das ist höhere
sonderzahlungen gibt dann werden wir bis
zu 3000 euro steuer- und abgabenfrei
ermöglichen das ist eine konkrete
botschaft des zusammenhalts in
deutschland und eine botschaft der tat
partnerschaft
sind also wir haben sehr viel gemacht um
die drängenden probleme vieler
bürgerinnen und bürger in den griff zu
bekommen und wir werden das auch weiter
tun weil das notwendig ist die maßnahmen
die wir gemacht haben haben wir auch
große erfahrung mit sich gebracht viele
haben hier sehr skeptisch diskutiert ich
erinnere mich an einige äußerungen aus
der union wenn ich das richtig dass wir
das neun euro ticket einführen und nicht
sage ausdrücklich das war eine große
sache die skeptiker hatten nicht recht
und deshalb wird es eine fortsetzung
geben für eine lösung die das möglich
macht bundesweit abonnierbare digital
buchbare tickets zu haben die zu einem
vertretbaren tarif überall in
deutschland die nutzung des nahverkehrs
möglich machen eine gute entscheidung
aus der krise gewachsen aber für viel
viel längere zeit sind wollen
was dann natürlich dazu kommt es dass
wir die herausforderung bewältigen
müssen die mit den steigenden
energiekosten verbunden sind wir haben
also als sie noch nicht daran gedacht
hatten schon das problem gelöst wie
sichern wir die energieversorgung
deutschlands
was nicht möglich gewesen ist denn die
cdu/csu ist die partei die die komplette
verantwortung dafür hat dass deutschland
ausstiegs entscheidung getroffen hat aus
der kohle und aus der atomenergie aber
die niemals die kraft hatte in
irgendetwas einzusteigen sie warnt
unfähig den aufbau der neuen energien
herbeizuführen
sie haben abwehrkämpfe geführt gegen
jede 1
inkraft anlage und jeder ab der kampf
der letzten jahre schadet unserem land
noch heute das kann sie
[Musik]
nach einigen eher dürftigen minuten
kommt olaf scholz jetzt wieder in fahrt
wir hören auch gleich wieder rein aber
eines ganz klar olaf scholz versucht den
schwarzen peter für die für das große
energieproblem was wir haben einzig der
union zu schieben das ist natürlich
falsch die spd hat über viele viele
jahre in der bundesregierung mitregiert
und sitzt natürlich auch an den
schalthebeln der macht in vielen
bundesländern von daher das ding ist
zwar souverän rüber gekommen aber stimmt
einfach nicht
verantwortliche cdu politik die uns die
jetzige situation gebracht
hallo herr merz
hören sie genau zu
als ich vorgeschlagen hatte in der
bundesregierung wir sollten doch
flüssiggas cremans bauen an den
norddeutschen kürzen wir sollten doch
flüssiggas terminals an den deutschen
küsten bauen und wir dazu einen brief
entwickelt hatten hat ein mitglied der
bundesregierung vermutlich cdu dass dem
spiegel gesteckt damit sich alle darüber
aufregen dass wir das tun hätten wir es
man getan will ich ausdrücklich dazu
sagen dann müssen wir jetzt nicht mit
diesem tempo das machen
und eine partei die bis heute fast jede
windkraftanlage persönlich bekämpft hat
überhaupt nichts zu tun mit der frage
wie lösen geriet energieversorgungs
probleme der zukunft das ist die
wahrheit wir aber haben in diesem jahr
schon mehrere gesetze auf den weg
gebracht und werden noch weitere auf den
weg bringen die dazu führen dass wir in
dem notwendigen schnellen tempo den
ausbau von erneuerbaren energien
zustande kriegen offshore wind onshore
wind solaranlagen ein starkes
leistungsfähiges netz und
selbstverständlich alles was dazu gehört
ja polemik wird dazu das muss auch sein
in so einer bundestagsdebatte die
natürlich spannungsgeladen ist aber
wichtig zu wissen und das sollten auch
unsere zuschauer wissen es waren vor
allem auch die grünen die sich in den
letzten jahren vehement auch noch zu
jahresbeginn gegen den bau von lng
terminals ausgesprochen haben also die
sitzen in den eigenen reihen für olaf
scholz höhere schnell wieder rein
dafür tragen sie die verantwortung
es war unverantwortlich das zu tun und
es ist gut dass sie in der opposition
sind damit wir die industrielle
modernisierung unseres landes hinkriegen
damit wir wettbewerbsfähig bleiben und
uns nicht mehr vor den problemen dieses
landes drücken
ja wir müssen unabhängig werden von den
gasimporten aus russland und das werden
wir in großer geschwindigkeit tun in
wilhelmshaven in stade in wulsbüttel in
lubmin werden neue terminals entstehen
wir haben an den westeuropäischen kosten
mit unseren freunden gesprochen in den
niederlanden in belgien dass sie die
terminals aufbauen und die
leitungskapazität mit frankreich das das
erste mal gas zu uns liefern wird wir
haben probleme gelöst da hatten sie noch
gar nicht mitgekriegt dass die überhaupt
existieren und das ist das was wir jetzt
zustande gebracht haben mit den
terminals im norden und mit denen an den
deutsch besten europäischen küsten
werden wir eine sichere
energieversorgung für deutschland
gewährleisten
was aber natürlich auch dazu gehört und
das will ich dazu sagen ist dass wir
jetzt mit denen nachdem wir die
versorgungssicherheit zum großen thema
gemacht haben auch das problem mit den
preisen in den griff nehmen und deshalb
ist es richtig dass wir sagen wir werden
das mag design auf dem strommarkt
verändern wir werden nicht zulassen dass
die hohen preise die für strom aus
gaskraftwerken heute gezahlt werden dazu
führen dass es extra große profite geht
für jemanden der das mit windkraft mit
wasserkraft mit solarenergie der das
macht mit braunkohle und steinkohle oder
nuklearenergie sondern wir werden diese
zusätzlichen gewinne abschöpfen um die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu entlasten mit
einer strompreis bremse das ist die
richtige antwort und wir haben sie
gegeben
und natürlich werden wir uns mit der
frage der gaspreise auseinandersetzen
müssen und der hohen kohlepreise und
ölpreise die ja alle davon auch mit
berührt sind wir haben uns darum
gekümmert dass das möglich ist wir
sorgen jetzt dafür dass wir zusammen mit
europa diskutieren wie kriegen wir das
thema im griff denn anders als beim
strommarkt geht es ja darum dass sie ihr
importieren aus ländern die die preise
anderswo bestimmt aber wir müssen
trotzdem hinkriegen dass sich das ändert
das erste was wir hinkriegen müssen ist
das wenn wir das geschafft haben worum
wir uns jetzt im eiltempo kümmern und
sich vorher niemand gekümmert hat
nämlich dass wir jeder zeit gas aus
aller welt importieren können mit den
ganzen terminals über die ich eben
gesprochen hat dass wir den
weltmarktpreis nur bezahlen müssen und
nicht die höheren preise die durch diese
fehlenden import strukturen heute
aufgerufen werden aber wenn wir das
geschafft haben dann geht es jetzt auch
darum dass wir den weg beschreiten wie
wir diese preise nach unten kriegen das
werden wir mit unseren freunden in
europa und mit allen hier in deutschland
erörtern denn das ist eine sache die wir
nicht auf sich beruhen lassen die preise
für die energielieferung müssen runter
die bürgern und bürger müssen die preise
auch bezahlen können und wir werden
dafür sorgen
wir erleben eine zeitenwende ich habe
das hier im deutschen bundestag gesagt
das ist der russische angriffskrieg auf
die ukraine der die europäische
friedens- und sicherheitsrat nung
zertrümmert hat der unverändert eine
riesige große bedrohung ist für frieden
und sicherheit in europa denn das war ja
die verständigung der letzten jahrzehnte
dass das nicht passiert dass man mit
gewalt grenzen verschiebt und etwas
anderes ist es nicht als imperialismus
was der russische präsident versucht
sich nicht mich einfach teile des
nachbar territoriums oder das ganze
anzueignen und man darf ihn auch nicht
missverstehen er hat das ja alles
öffentlich gesagt in aufsätzen
geschrieben es gibt überhaupt nichts an
der frage zu deutschland was seine
absicht ist deshalb unterstützen wir die
ukraine mit unseren verbündeten wir tun
es schon sehr lange und wir tun es sehr
effektiv auch mit den notwendigen
schweren waffen mit artillerie mit
möglichkeiten zur luftverteidigung und
all dem was wir auf den weg gebracht
haben das sind die modernsten waffen die
exakt jetzt in dem gefecht im osten der
ukraine gebraucht werden wir werden das
auch weiter tun das ist unsere
verpflichtung so lange wie es notwendig
ist
und es ist sehr umfangreich was wir
getan haben aber eins unterscheidet uns
von ihnen ganz offensichtlich sie haben
es heute bekannt wir werden keine
alleingänge machen wir werden keine
deutschen alleingänge machen das wäre
ein schwerer schwerer
unverantwortlicher fehler und ich sage
ausdrücklich an die union gerichtet wer
für alleingänge plädiert sollte dieses
land nicht regieren
und was wir tun was wir tun ist
eingebettet in die gemeinsamen handlung
mit unseren verbündeten insbesondere den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und wer
nicht verstehen will wer genau begreifen
will was die regierung leitet der
braucht nur den aufsatz von präsident
biden in der new york times durchlesen
oder exakt das erzählt hat was ich ihnen
hier auch sagen erstens wir werden als
verbündete handeln wir werden keine
entscheidungen treffen die dazu führen
dass der krieg in russland
verbrecherischer weise gegen die ukraine
führt zu einer eskalation eines krieges
führt zwischen nato und russland aber
wir werden das notwendige tun und genau
entlang dieser linie denkt eingebettet
in das bündnis in mit unseren freunden
in aller welt unterstützen wir die
ukraine und werden es so lange machen
wie es notwendig ist
das sind ernste zeiten es sind ernste
zeiten in denen der zusammenhalt in der
gesellschaft von allergrößter bedeutung
ist und deshalb sind es auch zeiten in
denen sich immer wieder beweisen muss zu
was wir miteinander fähig sind ich bin
überzeugt wir sind ein land das diesen
zusammenhalt auch hat das in der lage
ist die schwierige zeit zu bewältigen in
der wir uns jetzt befinden und dass auch
in der lage ist den weg in die zukunft
zu beschreiten das haben wir gemacht mit
weitreichenden entscheidungen in diesem
jahr weit reichende entscheidung als sie
in den letzten jahrzehnten über alle
zeit hinweg verteilt worden sind in
einem einzigen jahr das ist die aufgabe
der regierung und das werden wir auch
weiter zu tun
[Applaus]
ja das war jetzt die rede von
bundeskanzler olaf scholz die begann
sehr emotional fünf minuten quasi
rechtfertigung olaf scholz hat dann
seine regierungspolitik erklärt er hat
immer wieder appelliert er hat gesagt
dass deutsche ein starkes land ist was
ich in dieser krise unterhaken wird und
hat vor allem die opposition
oppositionsführer friedrich merz mit
viel kritik bedacht hat auch immer
gesagt die cdu eigentlich die partei die
verhindert hat dass deutschland beim
thema energiewende weiter ist als es
aktuelles die dafür extrem
mitverantwortlich ist dass deutschland
in dieser schwierigen
energiekrise ist und ich glaube jetzt
gleich geht's hier weiter im programm
aber das war eine spannende rede war
eine sternstunde wie so schön heißt des
parlamentes
[Musik]